do you think we even go to sleep
okay so thanks for staying until the
last Talk of the workshop we have we are
very happy to have Professor Adam
weirdman from Caltech for the last talk
um Adam has received numerous
prestigious awards from multiple
societies IEEE communication societies
within benefits asym sigmatrix test of
five award multiple newspaper Awards uh
teaching Awards
um we all know him for his uh
influential work on data centers today
we're going to talk about learning to
control safety critical systems thank
you thanks for sticking around for the
last talk uh I really appreciate it uh
so please uh interject we're a small
crowd so uh ask me questions as we go
along uh there's some new things here so
just a paper finish last night I I tried
to put some of the results in here so
some of it it's the first time I'm
presenting so please uh if it's not
clear let me know and I'll I'll go into
the details they're fresh in mind still
um okay so this is Joint work uh over a
bunch of different projects in my group
uh and so these are some students and
postdocs that have worked uh on things
in this area the boxes on the you know
the four on the left are people who have
now gone on to other places uh uh for
faculty positions and the the six on the
right are the ones that are still at
Caltech and I'll put faces along
projects as we go along so you can see
who has worked on the web
um and then yeah so the motivation for
this talk is kind of the motivation for
a lot of the work in our group right now
uh you know a very kind of standard
stereotypical motivation right now that
many of us could use but to make it a
little bit more precise one AI certainly
has a huge potential and and in our
group we're really worried about uh sort
of realizing that potential when it
comes to resiliency and sustainability
of network systems uh typically
infrastructure systems like
Transportation electricity grid and
cloud computing uh and you know the
natural question you know the motivating
question for a lot of Grants these days
is our AI tools ready and the of course
the answer is no uh as of today
especially for these 60 critical
applications and I think you know my
favorite picture highlighting this uh is
this one it's getting a little bit old
but I think it's still really compelling
uh it's you know the stop sign on the
left has a few pieces of tape and to the
vision recognition system it's
interpreted as a speed limit sign
because of those pieces of tape and
that's uh you know not something that
can be explained very easily this is a
problem of interpretability in the model
and you know the ability to generate
this sort of adversary real example for
these deep learning tools is really
should give you pause in terms of
deploying these things in safety
critical systems
I like to keep this example in mind as a
big motivation for our work and you know
then there's plenty of news stories one
can come up with around failures of
deployment of AI Tools in these safety
critical systems uh and you know I think
all that has uh you know happily
culminated in a document that I think is
actually really important that was
released last week which is an AI Bill
of Rights this isn't a Bill of Rights
for AI entities this is a Bill of Rights
for how AI should be managed in our
lives as a society so if you haven't
read this yet I highly recommend reading
it there were a number of academics our
peers that were involved in drafting it
and putting it out and you know I think
the first bullet point in it is maybe
the one relevant for this talk it says
that we as people in in the US should be
protected from unsafe and ineffective AI
systems in our lives and right now we
don't have a tool set to do that often
uh in terms of deploying AI so I think
it's really crucial uh you know it's
nice to see this formalized and it's
really crucial in terms of a direction
to build safety uh you know tools that
allow us to get that safety from AI you
can see many of the other ones that are
relevant to the semester here in these
bullets as well
in terms of it's a good goal goal posts
for us as a community
and to make this really concrete so you
mentioned that I work on data center
design and sustainable data center
design so this is uh you know something
that we've been working on for over a
decade now and for those who haven't
thought about it the the sort of uh 20
000 foot picture of this is if you want
to make a data center sustainable and
carbon you know reduce their carbon
footprint then you want to manage
workloads at the data centers in a way
where you're running things more when
there's renewable energy available
unless when there's not and you do this
by taking advantage of flexibility in
the workloads on-site energy storage and
many other other things in the design
and so designing these systems is
something we've been working on for a
while and in the last few years it's
really become a reality uh that these
systems are out in the wild at most
major uh you know large-scale tech
companies are doing something along
these lines this is a Google price
release around their system which is now
doing this not just in local sites but
in geographically distributed ways and I
like to use this one here here because
Anna who's the team leader actually came
out of this community for her PhD and
her work so it's a success story of
someone from our community going and
driving uh these things at the industry
scale as well but this is clearly a
place where AI tools seem really
relevant uh you know you can predict
when solar is going to be available
when's winds going to be available when
the workloads will be what how much
flexible workloads you're having and it
seems like you know that's got to be the
core of this you make use of that in a
in these system designs and within
Google deepmind you know had a number of
splashy press release about you know the
possibilities of doing this reducing
data center cooling bills by 40 using
these deep prediction Tools in these
designs but when you look at what's
actually being released not just at
Google but other had other companies
what's used in practice it's not these
AI tools it's all robust optimization
based designs uh and you know the reason
is exactly the motivation I've been
giving you can't afford to fail at scale
in these situations you need guarantees
so you can't just throw deep X
at this stuff and hope that you don't
get a you know a bad scenario in your
deployment you have to do things with
guarantees and so to make that really
concrete this is now from a simulation
uh in our group uh where you take you
know our ml based as a you know deep RL
based uh tool for doing data center
management not ml based is a robust
online optimization based Tool uh and
here this is distribution shift between
training and test which you know you can
think of as the Sim to real gap for
these systems if you're you know testing
things in the lab versus deploying it
um and you know this point here at xero
is that it's less than 40 here but is
that significant win from using deep RL
Tools in this space and what happens is
with a fairly minor distribution shift
uh you all of a sudden get massive uh
really bad cost compared to if you just
did the you know classic non-ml based
designs in this
so the x-axis here is distribution shift
so think of this as uh the error between
the distribution you train the ML on and
the real distribution of when solar
workloads that you experience and so the
scale here isn't very meaningful but
think of this as not a huge amount like
moderate difference
and so you know this is bad because if
you deploy and you're out here you're
giving up a huge amount compared to you
know your old robust tool but of course
if things are working well you you want
to exploit that gain and so uh you know
big win at training is good big risk of
distribution shifts what you want to
deploy is something that looks more like
this where you get most of that game but
you're still protecting yourself uh in
the events that you're off if you have
us into real Gap as much
okay so that's the goal in cartoon form
uh simplistic form and so you know in
one sentence it's can you get those
guarantees uh that are required in order
to deploy these things in safety
critical systems uh and you know in in
uh sort of Pareto optimality form you
can sort of caricature the current world
as you have these black box tools you
have these traditional online algorithms
you want to expand that Pareto Frontier
uh by you know getting better you know
nearly that performance and better
robustness than you can get there and
you know in in sort of typical lingo
this is combining model free and model
based tools to get the best of both
worlds and you know over the last three
four more years there's a ton of work
with a ton of different approaches uh
going at that middle ground and you know
I I put a few here there's many more I
tried to include some things from people
I thought would be in the room here uh
for today uh but you know this is a
while list where I can adapt to whatever
the audience looks like
um and so but that's not what I'm going
to talk about today so today I'm going
to talk about a particular way of doing
this which as in this semester we've
heard a bunch of talks about which is
learning augmented algorithms and for
learning augmented algorithms you'll
notice that this changed from untrusted
or from model free model based to
untrusted expert and trusted experts and
so this perspective is that you treat
the Black Box AI as a you know expert
that may be good or maybe terrible and
you don't know and you treat the uh you
know traditional algorithms as trusted
experts meaning they come with a
guarantee if you always follow their
advice you'll achieve that guarantee and
your goal then is to you know use this
to make sure you have a guarantee but
exploit this in case it's good
that's the goal and you know the
architecture of these learning augmented
algorithms looks like this so you have
an input you run your the key thing here
is that these are black boxes you get
your untrusted prediction and your
trusted prediction and you have no idea
how those are coming to you you just get
those predictions you put plug those
into some sort of meta algorithm and
that meta algorithm combines these two
expert predictions to you know give you
your action uh and then you want that
action to satisfy the best of both
worlds
yes yeah so this is robustness and
consistency uh so I'll get to that in a
second and so the the key algorithmic
design question here is how should
advice be used do you switch between
them do you combine them you know that
that's the algorithmic question and as
was just said the the studerada here are
you want to do simultaneously uh get
yourself consistency which is match the
performance of the AI expert if the AIX
operator is good and you know that means
that like if the untrust expert is bad
this is sort of trivially satisfied so
this is only binds only as type one that
expert is good but then at the same time
you don't want to give up too much and
so you want a worst case competitive
ratio and ideally you want that worst
case competitive ratio to be sort of
near the best competitive ratio you
could get for The Trusted algorithm so
you're not giving up too much yeah
you can't think of like books approaches
so typically you know learning augmented
thinks of these things as black boxes
it's it's nice to you know as you know
go and get into this so I'll come back
at the end to some like gray box
versions of this uh but I think if
you're truly white box then you're in
the sort of like combining model 3 Model
based framework uh it's it's a little
bit you know different I the I think I
like this I mean you you you're the core
of it uh I like this because you know
you can really as I'll say in a second
actually I'll say it now like we've been
doing this stuff with companies and you
know there you think of think of the
company having a team that is exploring
whether this stuff is valuable a team
that's optimizing the current system uh
and now the you know CTO is making a
decision about whether to switch to this
uh there are two you know they're too
risk-averse to switch to it but now they
can combine what the two things that
those teams have done in a way and then
those teams can still work and you know
improve what they're doing and so they
can still just use this meta algorithm
to combine so this black box notes is
really useful from a practical
perspective and in deploying these
things
okay so so this uh is you know by
competitive guarantee
um
in the literature there's often also
other things that people care about so
smoothness means that you know think of
these as two endpoints if your
predictions are nearly perfect if your
predictions are terrible the in between
is of course valuable you want to have
smooth performance in between uh and
then uh one thing that's actually been
very important in our applications is
frugality or I guess Antonius calls it
succinctness uh where and this can go
both ways it could be that your
traditional algorithm is using some
non-convex optimization that is really
slow to compute and so you can get you
know quick machine learning predictions
in between can you still guarantee
robustness if you're not using the
trusted uh advice as often or vice versa
maybe your model is huge and hard to you
know it takes a lot of computation to
get an untrusted advice out of you know
and you can use that infrequently how
how you know few can you get away with
and still get good robustness and
consistency trade-offs so this has been
a really important question for the
applications we're talking about
but I won't talk about those today okay
so to make this really concrete let me
give you an example uh in the control
space so in control you know the classic
maybe dominant algorithm is model
predictive control which basically just
follows the predictions in a certain GE
equivalent way uh and then recomputes
your actions and so uh this is to give
credit this is a you know physical
deployment in our uh uh wind tunnel
there's a massive fan here that can do
lots of crazy uh wind Dynamics uh and so
you can be really unpredictable in what
the wind Dynamics look like and this is
guanya's thesis who's starting at CMU
this year
um and he's a photographer so anytime
this beautiful picture of the infinity
symbol being done by the drums I have to
put that up there but uh the idea here
is you know if you have high quality
prisons model predictive control works
really well uh if you give it so that's
consistency if you have low quality
predictions and you treat them as if
they're true certainly equivalent you're
of course going to do terrible and so
you know you don't get robustness
and this is sort of the traditional view
like most uh most kind of control
algorithms in the space really can't do
well in the space and here the
uncertainty is coming from like the wind
Dynamics
okay so learning augmented algorithms
we've heard a lot about them this term I
think this is like the sixth or maybe
tenth top that has put up this web
bibliography if you want to follow the
field uh go to that website and you can
see like the live update of papers that
people are publishing in this space
there's a ton of different models you
know I I have added a couple since the
last time I had this slide up but I
still I'm not including all the models
that people have proven things here on
uh there's a ton at this point and so
the my goal in this talk is to do a
little bit of an overview but do an
overview in the context of a specific
model that I think is a really nice
place to show
algorithmic complexity algorithmic
limits uh for for learning augmented
algorithms and it's one that I think we
haven't seen uh in the semester yet so
it's good for that reason too and so
we're going to do it in convex body
chasing and my goal is to tell a story
of like the complexities of algorithm
design and what you gain from having
complexity here and what you what the
limits are of simple designs so what is
convex body chasing uh it's exactly what
it says this is a two-dimensional toy
example so you haven't you start at some
point you're presented with a body you
have to choose a new action which is in
that body you just care that you're in
that body there's no differential in
cost depending on where you are in the
body you move to that point the cost you
pay is the distance to move
and then you're given a new body you
choose a new action cost to pay is the
distance and so on
okay so it's very simple clean to define
a nice beautiful Theory problem uh you
know you have your constraints from your
bodies to fit the theme of the workshop
and you have the costs from your
movement
[Music]
um and you know the challenge here is
because you don't know the future bodies
and they could be chosen adversarially
uh you don't know where to go in the
current body
that's the that's the challenge here
algorithmically
uh and so it has a long history uh I'll
talk I'm hoping that I get to it about
Connections to control uh and robust
control is the last you know five
minutes of the talk uh but there's a lot
of applications to data centers in this
and and a lot of the applications come
from this can be you know really reduced
to you know function online convex
optimization switching costs various
online control problems so algorithms
that you design for convex body chasing
can immediately Port into these uh other
domains fairly directly with you know
fairly General assumptions
so there's been a lot of work with our
group and a lot of Hassan's group um
using these sorts of tools in those
settings
okay so uh lots of algorithmic progress
uh without going through the who did
what when uh of the sequence this is
state of the art uh I'll I'll be
focusing on this D rather than writing
the D root D log T but I'd say root D is
probably the right answer and this log T
is an annoyance
um and uh but it's a very hard annoyance
to get rid of
um and root D is the lower bound and D
is the dimension of the action space
here Little D is the dimension of the
action space
and so you know in a classical online
algorithms Viewpoint it's kind of almost
nailed this route this log T being the
missing Gap uh uh and it's a simple
thing intuitively you want to move
because you have to be conservative the
adversary can give you anything next you
want to move to some sort of notion of
center of the bodies and the notion of
center that is right is the functional
Steiner point is basically the message
to take away
and so as this indicates this means that
you're quite conservative and if we come
back and we think about what ml advice
can buy you you know you the Steiner
point is going to have you move to some
sort of Center if you know what's coming
you can you know be extreme and in this
example you move once and you never move
again and it's way way better if the
advice was good but if the advice was
bad it could you know force you to you
know go in the other direction and now
you have massive movement unnecessarily
chasing around a spiral yeah the one
feature of this
inner point policy so this uh seems
surprising to an outsider so do you have
any comment on this um
it's the adversarial conservativeness
right so if you do anything else you can
be exploited uh the first results were
did depend on where you were it was a
greedy projection uh you know greedy
projection can get you reasonable
results in some situations especially in
nested bodies
um but it's just not as good as this
I don't remember off the top of my head
it's it's got It's it's not uh it's
maybe even exponential in the
um but I I don't quote me I don't
remember exactly it's it's been we've
moved on so I forget the greeting in
that information
my my cash isn't large enough
um okay so the algorithmist question
then is if we're gonna do well with
these advice we need to understand you
know when we should switch between them
how much memory we should use all these
are the questions that we want to answer
in terms of using this advice and so
starting off the way most learning
augmented uh you know models start off
is you first just do something naive in
terms of switching algorithms and you
know the naive thing as a you know
theorist is some sort of doubling
algorithm uh where you play you have you
know if you think just a little bit you
realize you have to start with the
untrusted advice because otherwise your
consistency is terrible because the you
could just be off immediately and you
know never recover if the adversary
stops the instance there so you have to
start with the untrusted advice and
eventually you have to switch to the
trusted advice if the untrusted device
is bad so you need some idea of when to
switch and the doubling trick often
works well as a you know starting
Baseline for these algorithms you travel
some distance R when you hit R you
switch to the trusted advice algorithm
then you do another R then you double r
and repeat and this has the advantage of
if one is doing very well you spend more
time in it if one is doing very badly
you spend less time in it and so it sort
of self-balances the exploration across
the algorithms in a smooth way and
because you're doubling you're never
hurt too much from choosing the wrong
one compared to your total aggregate
cost
so this is the you know the way that you
do it and you know just emphasizing the
Black Fox nature I don't care you know
what the advice is coming from in the
style algorithm and then of course you
don't actually choose R and you you
optimize this to bias you know to
balance your uh sort of consistency and
robustness something like this gives you
a result in the body chasing space uh
only in the nested case is it an
interesting result but it nested means
you know your initial body is big and
everything else is you know nested in it
as you go forward in time and so there
you can get a OnePlus Delta consistency
and then you pay inverse Delta in
robustness and then the D here is just
from the best known uh you know uh
existing competitive ratio here for the
in the center point algorithms and so
the this capital D is the diameter of
the action space well this will be an
important thing this is this is really
bad that that's that the diameter is
showing up in our practical applications
uh you know we don't the we don't want
diameter dependence uh because if you
think of the action space as being very
large then this hurts you a lot
yeah
so completely adversarial uh
yes yeah uh and so you know just to I
will do this only for the first one but
the if we think of a practical
perspective just a sec this is really
nice because now whatever deep RL you
apply to make your predictions all you
had to do is wrap these three lines of
code around it and all of a sudden you
have a provable adversarial bounds on
dfrl whatever variation you were trying
uh and you don't have to reprove it if
you change what you're doing from a
learning perspective you still have an
adversarial Bound for so this is the
power of this learning augmented
algorithms yeah
here means that all this context what is
uh picked in a compact sector 3DS
contamination yeah yeah there's some
ball over all of them that's a stack of
energy yeah
yeah
just competitive ratio basically is at
the base competitive Ratio or is it with
respect to the optimal algorithm which
was
the squared uh so we actually prove it
by comparing to the optimal algorithm
and then uh so so the way that we tend
to focus on proving these is this is by
competitive to opt or to like an
algorithm that's robust and to the
algorithm that follows predictions and
then you extend it to the optimal with
existing worst case results
okay so this was nested and you know
this is our baby starting point result
because I want to emphasize the
fundamental limit here and so uh
switching algorithms are not enough in
this space you can prove uh directly
that there's no switching algorithm uh
for the general case that can be better
than three consistent and this is bad
because then you have to give up a lot
compared to what your or your AIML tool
is doing and you know the whole point of
this is to nearly capture all the gain
of them so you really want one plus
Delta consistency with these algorithms
from from the perspective of exploiting
the uh
so that's one limit and then the other
limit we can prove in this is you need
to use memory if you're memoryless uh
then you can't have any robustness
guarantee uh or sorry you can't have any
consistency guarantee that it's
non-trivial and by that I mean you can't
have a consistency guarantee better than
the competitive ratio you can achieve if
you ignored predictions entirely
and so you know this gives us some space
to work for you have to be adaptive to
memory and you have to do something
smarter than switching if you're going
to get a guarantee like we want which
would be a one plus Delta consistency
result for General about ages
confidence
okay and so next try uh so next simple
try and this is kind of common across uh
learning on augmented algorithms you
start with switching that gives you a
baseline to beat uh then you try some
version of multiplicative weights uh or
your favorite K expert stack algorithm
and you see what you can get there
and in the multiplicative way oh go
ahead
yeah yeah yeah uh okay and so multiple
good weights this is Allah like lemon
Birch uh uh so it kind of actually uses
off the shelf of those and this is due
to Antonio's uh
uh in terms of result but so I don't
think I need to go over this it's just
you know multiple complaints applied
um so the result you can get there uh uh
is this following one so it's General
you apply multiple of Weights you get a
one plus Delta consistency this new is
the aggregate prediction quality so I'm
not going to talk about smoothness but
this means you get smoothness too uh
because if that quality is good uh or
bad it sort of just degrades linearly
with that
um but
uh and this actually is a very general
result so it applies broader to
electrical task systems and results like
this have been proven in other models as
well you know this this type of model
result is very common but it has a you
know annoyance here which is that
diameter is showing up and it's showing
up uh uh additively
um and there's another sort of weirdness
in the result which you'd expect as you
improve consistency like you expect a
like one plus Delta and then something
over Delta or something exponential and
Delta and robustness there's a one plus
Delta in both places and that's because
the Delta trade-off is really with this
adverse this additive term uh as you
improve Delta you pay more and more in
the additive term there in terms of the
diameter yeah
but emphasis when it does zero
oh so Ada's to think of it as one plus
uh in the way I've written it uh so like
perfect is perfect as one and then one
plus that's why
uh you you can you imagine you can
choose your Delta and make it all the
way go down
yeah but but you can counter that with
the Delta if you want so if I had chosen
a different Delta I could counter that
four
or no I couldn't no I couldn't uh so
maybe there's a
yeah
I maybe I have a typo here maybe it
should be a one plus
I'm not sure
thank you good catch this is a new slice
yeah another question
all right you whichever one wants to go
okay sorry
okay yo I'm just advice is that each
iteration you get the point of reticular
right is that yeah
um
I don't know uh yeah I mean
there's some equivalents right because
whatever information I give I will use
it to just give me the next step but
whether there would be some way of
getting a better robustness consistency
trade-off from using that to improve
that other information I don't think
there's a result saying yes or no to
that question
that's an interesting question
and you know what I'll say is you know
in general the question of what the
advice should be is a really interesting
question in this space yeah so you said
the memory is going to be important yeah
so this is not this is not very yeah so
so I'm doing this because it's common
not because it satisfies those
conditions so that I put so this is
multiplicative ways without memory and
well it has memory right because you're
updating your weights
based on uh the cost so you're so yeah I
skipped over this maybe too quickly but
you're updating your waves based on your
weights based on the cost in that round
which means that the weights have a full
memory of the costs embedded into them
right so you are you like the whole
sequence matters in terms of what the
weights are today foreign
if you switch between algorithms then
the state could be kind of hurting you
on both sides is
how this is solving that problem it's
not something
right this is a first cut it's an
off-the-shelf application of
multiplicative weights and you know it
gives you something right it gives you a
trade-off and some in some problems this
might be good enough but in the in the
body chasing context this diameter and
the sort of ends up hurting you a lot
and and because you know most of the
online learning things end up having the
diameter assumption in them it's a
little sometimes hard to see how that's
going to impact in these in these things
but yeah I'm trying to go through that
one quickly so my my goal here is to to
say like this doesn't work so we can
move on
um uh I mean it gives a nice result but
we want more than that and so the next
step uh and what you might think of is
like we haven't used convexity really
yet in either of the switching or the uh
multiplicative weights so let's use the
fact that our bodies are convex what
that lets us do is you know actually
choose something in between uh and
adaptively be in between depending on
the cost of the things at the edge uh
this helps and so this is one way of
doing it you can actually through this
reduce the problem to an online
algorithm problem called by competitive
line chasing so in bicompetitive line
chasing you always are choosing a point
on a line and you want to at every point
they have a you know competitive ratio
that is uh you know bounded compared to
both endpoints of the line so that's the
by competitive line chasing problem and
so you can use ideas from by competitive
line chasing to get a result here uh and
so and that algorithm that I'm skipping
over quickly gives you a non our first
non-diameter dependent result
uh and so here now even if the timer is
very large you get a nice bound you get
a root 2 plus Delta and then you pay
your Delta or your over Delta squared
here for the robustness
um and you know this is nice the
diameter the dependence on the diameter
is gone but it still leaves something
right because we're not getting one plus
Delta so this says you you know if
you're applying this to your deep RL
whatever you're paying a root 2 Factor
just because you're getting robustness
and you can't uh you can't sort of trade
off all the way back all the way down to
getting the full value of the uh our the
AI tool so we want to get to the OnePlus
Delta and so this motivates the question
is this a fundamental limit uh and uh
the answer is
no it took us a while to get here
actually uh and so we were able to you
know this is one of the new results uh
from this week is we were able to prove
a lower bound here that uh shows what is
possible to achieve so you get uh you
can be one plus Delta consistent uh with
a randomized algorithm here and uh but
you have to pay exponentially in
robustness to get it
so you know this one we're not paying
exponentially in robustness but we're
not getting the same consistency
guarantee uh if you want uh OnePlus
Delta robustness you need to pay
exponential in the robot or sorry one
less Delta consistency you need to pay
exponential on the robust instant
uh and this one I do want to give a
little bit of a sense of the proof uh
because the proof guides us to the
algorithm so the instance that you can
construct to prove this uh has this
flavor this it's a little bit more
complicated to Define but so think of
this as a cartoon of the instance not
not the exact thing but this will get
the cross to the main idea so think of
there being some body uh here on a face
and the Steiner point is going to give
you something in the middle but whatever
you're think of whatever your uh uh
trusted algorithm is doing it's giving
you something in the middle of that face
so the adversary is constructing this
and then the uh prediction
uh is on the boundary
uh so that's the you know the timeline
or at time T this is what you're doing
uh the diameter of this is going to be 2
to the T
and then the next body is going to be
such that the trusted advice doesn't
change
uh it's just hitting you know in a sort
of different dimension uh and the advice
is going to now move by 2 to the T
sort of boundary of that new body
and that new body has you know twice the
diameter of the previous body so now the
diameter is
and so in that way we're creating this
spiral where the device is moving
further and further away from you uh
from the uh trusted advice each round by
a factor of two
and you can do this in a way basically
and so the key property here is the cost
of the advice
uh is equal to the distance between the
advice and The Trusted uh suggestion
each round so that balance turns out to
be crucial to creating the instance
that balance is going to then give us
the you know the right way to sort of
make decisions in the algorithm as well
and then you know that just in case
you're curious how this works it's not
euclidean distance that's you know how
we can make this work
um and you know the proof then ends up
saying that you know like we said
already you have to start by following
the prediction uh and eventually you
need to move your mass back to that
trusted algorithm because it's much
better but the way this is set up you
can never move more than Delta over two
back
in each round and that's this is the
statement that requires most of the work
in the you know analysis of the instance
and once you have that statement that
means that you know if you just take
time equal to 1 over Delta you can only
have moved half of your mass back from
the you know untrusted advice to The
Trusted advice and that means that your
cost has to be at least two to the one
over Delta at that point
yeah
if my X domain is some bounded fixed
thing so
as my Horizon grows this will work for
an exponentially small Delta and then
not work anymore correct yeah and so
this is this is definitely like showing
the benefit you get from having bounded
diameter and you know a limit of what
you know how bad this instance can be if
you happen to diameter right so it
exploit you know shows why that's such a
you know challenge to get rid of
okay and so that key property here uh is
what guides us to the algorithm and so
this is the algorithm which uh Eco came
up with a great acronym for darts uh uh
discrete adaptive robust weight
transport
um and so it's sort of in the flavor of
the previous algorithm that skipped over
quickly where uh if you know I didn't
explain this case in that algorithm but
if you're uh uh if your robust algorithm
or it's like if your trusted algorithm
is just doing better than the robust
algorithm you just follow your untrusted
algorithm if there's you know a decision
that needs to be made you're updating
the probability of following the advice
the untrusted advice uh
with this ratio basically and this ratio
has that cost over the distance between
them and the motivation for that is
exactly that condition in the lower
bound argument
and that ratio turns out to be right and
then uh basically the the other the
other complexity in the algorithm uh but
this is sort of standard in a lot of
bublex work and others is that uh once
you have these probabilities you sample
through an optimal transport plan uh
that converts the previous uh
probability of following the device to
the new probability of following the
device so not that sort of transports
salmon and that distance is very
specific to get the cost to work out in
uh in this universe
so this transport is for coupling the
choice of yeah
from one step to the next exactly yeah
okay and then you know yeah I already
talked about that and so what's the
result you get well you get a result
matching the lower back you get that
your one plus Delta consistent and you
know two or two uh to the one over Delta
robust uh with the N coming from the uh
oh sorry that should be a d
yes and the really nice thing about this
algorithm is the same algorithm you
don't have to make any adjustments to it
uh Works in both generalizations of body
chasing and special cases of body
chasing you just need to tweak the
analysis of the algorithm a little bit
so the same algorithm gives you know
best state of the art results for uh the
bounded diameter case it matches what
you can get with multiplicative weights
uh it gives it for metrical task systems
which is a more General problem which is
this is the first one without the D it
gives it for a case server uh you get
state-of-the-art results that are
instead of Delta to the K just a linear
in Delta matching lower bounds now
finally there and this one I'm really
happy with I don't know how many people
are aware but K function chasing so if
you have distributed agents making
decisions chasing you know online
optimization problems uh you still get
the the same sort of results in the same
algorithm applying there yeah for your
rubber bands are you do you actually
have the information that you're giving
is like two points so that you assume
that it's one prediction and one context
but
for the you know the limiting results
though or for the lower Bound for the
lower bound is two two points okay yeah
one point
it's not clear yeah and so so if you
change the advice that uh the algorithms
are given I think it's a really
interesting question like different
advice should have different trade-offs
and you know there might be a better
advice that lets you get around this
exponential trade-off potentially I like
you know I really like that question
um okay so now let me come back to our
applications quickly so in the you know
I'm going to do this really close really
quick but you know that goal uh was
basically the result of running the
algorithm in the the data center case uh
and so you don't see that exponential
trade-off uh in a lot of these
distribution shift examples and so you
can really you know give up a couple
percent uh with distribution shift and
still uh capture the gain from the uh
you know AI the Deep RL tool in the data
center case you can do the same thing
this was this is a collaboration with
the company and the sort of utility
space uh so you can do co-generation for
the grid where you have conventional
generation gas and turbines and you have
wind and solar and you're trying to
manage them together same sort of thing
this actually does even better in terms
of the robustness guarantee uh that you
maintain while taking advantage of it uh
the Drone trajectory example you can do
the same thing and so here this is the
same animation I showed earlier now I'm
going to change the right hand side to
you use an algorithm that's a learning
augmented algorithm specialized to
control and the red is what NPC so I've
made the predictions even worse and the
blue you can see a little Gap there but
the blue is really able to avoid the
predictions that are bad and still get
very good performance even with uh
terrible predictions
so that's that's my first piece that I
have 15. I was wondering so okay so I'm
going through applications quickly so
now I've spent on this problem but as
we've got been getting questions there's
lots of other interesting problems in
learning augmented design uh Beyond this
I'll come back at the end to a full list
of some or not full list but a larger
list but I want to highlight one more uh
to close my Loop in this talk which is
around this box in the pipeline so so
far I've assumed you know enough to give
to run a trusted algorithm and that's a
big assumption in reality so in reality
there's some system that you have a
maybe flawed model of uh that you're you
know running your trust amount trusted
algorithm using those predictions of so
uh in reality you need to learn the
model to be able to compute The Trusted
algorithm in the first place uh
otherwise your guarantees for this are
all useless uh you know to begin with so
to make that really concrete uh we'll
look at a control example and then I'll
actually connect this back to body
chasing in terms of the algorithm we use
for this uh control example uh but so
this all the results here hold more
generally than this but I know this
isn't a control audience so I'll use the
simplest model here so this is just a
linear system time invariant so we have
uh you know our Dynamics our A and B W
is our noise I'm emphasizing it because
we're going to talk about adversarial
and stochastics cases here uh and just
quadratic costs for now so just lqr
um
now if a and b are known then I can you
know synthesize a controller with
robustness properties huge literature
doing this and then I can plug it into
meta algorithms and I can design a meta
algorithm that's specific to control and
I can give you robustness and
consistency guarantees and that's what
these people did in a couple papers uh
so control case if the model is known we
can do sort of the the version of the
story that we just talked
but
they can be aren't really no uh right so
you have to learn A and B and so in that
case now all of a sudden you really care
whether noise is stochastic and
adversarial since we're in the safety
critical world we want to think about
the address noise case and I that should
seem like completely intractable because
how do you learn A and B if your noise
is adversarial like it doesn't doesn't
pattern match right and so let's come to
the stochastic piece first and we'll
learn something and we'll go back to the
adversarial case so in the stochastic
case there's been a ton of work on this
learning to control uh over the last few
years by lots of you know very smart
groups uh and the without going through
all of it again summarizing state of the
art there's a really nice paper this
year at Colts by uh Shaheen uh who's at
Caltech working with Rebecca CB where
you combine Thompson sampling for
exploration with linear regression to
fit the A and B and you get a rooty
regrets even without knowing ahead of
time that there exists a stabilized
controller or controllability
assumptions or things like that you get
it very generally
it's a nice paper if you haven't read it
but the thing I want to focus on is this
like M which are the dimensions of the A
and B you have exponential dependence in
that and this is not like a drawback of
their algorithm because if you want to
learn A and B you need at least order in
samples which then means you're going to
suffer in your state Norm as you're
taking those samples which means that
you're going to have at least you know
two to the order and regret for anything
you do if you're learning A and B
so this is sort of often viewed as just
an unavoidable uh issue there but
do you really need to learn A and B
you certainly don't need to learn the
whole thing uh you know if your system
is self-stabilizing you don't need to
learn anything if all you care about is
stability you just run uh you don't care
what A and B are
uh and you know if it's nearly stable
you shouldn't need to learn very much to
stabilize it
and so we've I think this is a really
motivating question we have a first
paper on this that's going to be a nurse
this year
that gives a cut at it which you know
gives an algorithm that can stabilize
the system after order K samples where K
is the number of unstable modes of the
system and so instead of depending on
the system scale you just depend on how
unstable the system is linearly
and so this then gets you a stable
controller and then you plug in all the
results about you know learning low
regret and you can have a pipeline that
learns low regret without knowing
stabilizing and can do it quickly if you
have a system that is merely stable
so this is I think a good start and now
I want to come back to the adversarial
case because this now intuition says we
don't really care about learning
we care about if all we want to do is
stabilize the system we just care about
knowing enough about the Dynamics to
carve out the unstable notes
and that's now something we can maybe do
in the adverb stereo case even though we
don't have any distributional
assumptions
and so in the adversarial case now we're
going to make use of body chasing to not
do learning but to do consistency
chasing uh of the model so what does
that mean it means uh you know I'll use
the Drone example so we're trying to
track some trajectory within some safety
region so we imagine a priori there's
some set of models that could be true
for the system so uh here we'll assume
that this has a bounded diameter because
you know we have some idea of where the
system might live
uh we just start with an arbitrary
choice of those models maybe Steiner
code maybe something else uh and then we
synthesize the controller as if that was
the A and B for the system
okay so that we can do with standard
control theoretic techniques
then we run that system we run it for a
while observing the system's response to
it if we ever get to a point where we
might run into some sort of safety issue
uh we stop it we then take that batch of
points and we update the set of models
that are consistent with the data we've
seen about the system
so in our model space that means we look
at a nested convex body
and so now the set of models that are
consistent with what we've seen as a
nested set of our original set so that
rules out our current model because
otherwise we wouldn't have been in an
unsafe region uh and so then we choose a
new Point within that nested body we
synthesize the controller based on that
we run the system again when we get to a
point where something went unexpected we
know that we our model was invalid our
model wasn't consistent with the system
anymore
uh we update our set we look at a new
convex body we keep going
um so that's the algorithm so we're
using body chasing to chase consistent
models for our control system
now the result you can prove combining
you know everything I did in the first
part with uh some uh control theory for
doing the sort of you need not just you
you're not considered I'm a little
simplified here you need to synthesize
an optimal controller with a little bit
of robustness so an optimal robust uh
controller here uh and so you needed to
put those two things together and what
you can prove then is this guarantees
stability of an unknown system or
completely unknown no assumptions on it
uh on a single trajectory with a finite
mistake now so there's a finite number
of steps here where you're going to need
to recompute and risk going out of your
safety system
and so this is the first result that I'm
aware of for the adversarial assumptions
here uh and I've explained the simple
version of it this applies to time
varying systems adversarial disturbances
and it implies in distributed agents
where you have just agents distributed
in a network doing distributed control
where there's communication delay on the
information of the action and the
responsible system between agents and so
we can do that because we can take
advantage of system level synthesis SLS
results in the control Community which
has kind of happened in the last few
years
and so you know empirically what does
this mean this is a simple single agent
system right here uh but you take you
know this sort of algorithm and you
compare it with like uh you know a sort
of exploration and linear regression
style system ideabic approach and you
just you avoid that massive jump at the
beginning because you're not trying to
learn the whole system so you don't need
to explore all these states to learn A
and B you can just you know move only if
you're a consistency if your consistent
Choice causes a problem
and then we've applied this now in the
smart grid setting to do voltage control
and so the story here is you have a grid
some part of the grid just fails so you
don't know your new network model uh so
you have to you know update your
controller based on this new network
that is there you need to do it quickly
otherwise the Cascade is going to fail
uh this blue is what happens if you kind
of do uh you know a new estimate your
controller is wrong uh the Orange is
what happens with consistent modding
checks and anything that goes past this
region means that you have power outages
and so we're able to stabilize without
outages without knowing anything about
what the new network is only that a line
failed so that we have a nested model
okay so that's it uh sorry my phone is
special
um
okay so that that's the the last result
did anybody want to ask a question about
that one
conclude all right so uh the idea today
was to give some idea of algorithm
design and some little limits of
learning augmented algorithms using
convex body chasing as an example uh so
I talked mainly about you know how to
switch between them how to combine them
memory versus switching algorithms
versus taking advantage of structure uh
and I gave one example of you know how
you can apply this stuff on top uh to
sort of uh you know learn the model to
be able to even have the trusted expert
in the first place uh and I think this
has a nice like uh you know uh nested
doll type story because now in using the
body chasing you could actually use a
device on what the model was from the
Thompson sampling type uh you know tools
which then you could apply the
robustness and consistency results in
learning the model so that then you
could apply the robustness and
consistency results and so there's a
nice like uh you know nested application
of these results to even learn the model
that I think is pretty exciting
um but then you know some of you have
already been asking the the the more
General I think the big open questions
in this space which are I think the
biggest one maybe is this one this was
all for one version of what's the
untrusted advice was giving you uh it
doesn't have to give you a prediction of
the action it could give you more
information it could be in our case it
could be predicting the bodies it could
be giving you a like look ahead window
of bodies like NPC usually takes it
could be prediction uncertainty about
the action in addition to the action and
giving you that uncertainty
quantification uh one that we're really
interested in is you know if you assume
this is doing some sort of Q fun you
learning now you can actually feed the Q
function uh to The Meta algorithm and
that gives you a lot more power and so
we have one result that we're working on
there that does that in the control
context but I think that's an idea that
anchor moija did at Colts this past year
as well in a different context
and then uh you know here another one
that I think is really interesting that
we're spending some some brain power on
uh with Chalet Wren uh is the idea of
everything I've described and most of
the literature views the ml black box as
static
uh it doesn't improve the ml through the
process of applying the learning
augmented algorithm and you know that
training should be happening through the
system as well can you prove results
then about you know learning within the
context of the online problem and how
does that affect what sort of
consistency robustness trade-offs you
can prove I think that's a really
interesting question
all of these things kind of add
complexity Beyond you know the first
wave of results looking at you know
multiplicative weights and switching
algorithms there's a lot more you can do
if you take advantage of these other
aspects of the problem to get really
sophisticated things and push the
fundamental limits that that are
starting to be understood for these
topics
and then you know I guess coming back
completely you know smoothness regality
memory dependence are all really
interesting questions and then another
one that I haven't seen much on
especially when you start to look at the
ml model being trained online is average
case results uh about learning uh the
correct action during the during the
instance as well
six
okay so here's references from our group
uh in addition to the you know ones that
were in the talk for other groups thank
you
yeah so you have this blog diagram
so I'm starting to map this diagram to
the example to the case of the Acura
problem so the the last case was only
how to learn this model
okay it doesn't fit in like it's it's a
question of you know if you're actually
deploying this stuff you can't assume
that the model is known a priori you
have to learn the model and you maybe
have to do that online as you're
deploying this sort of thing and you
still want to maintain those guarantees
foreign
sampling is looking at uh
yeah so it's it's still looking it's
looking at regret this is looking at
stability so that's one difference uh so
learning just a stabilizing controller
but you can that's a sort of superficial
difference because once you've learned a
stabilizing controller then you can
apply whatever you want to get regret
balance after that uh the key difference
is here our goal was to not have
dependence on that
okay so here they're you're learning the
whole A and B to get low regret and
because you're learning the whole A and
B uh you have dependence on the size of
the whole AMD uh here we're saying that
we can learn with rate uh dependent only
on the number of unstable nodes and so
if it's very unstable K could be n but
in many systems K is going to be a small
constant and so this is going to be you
know order of magnitude faster
regret appears to be almost yeah
yeah definitely definitely changes by
changing the goal
that's yeah that's one interpretation
but I'll add on to that that's that's a
little bit of a false distinction
because one I think there's many regret
algorithms that start from the
assumption that you know a stabilizing
controller and so you can just add the
next step of the pipeline uh to I know a
stabilizing controller and then you run
any of those algorithms some things work
well and because you have you know a
small number of unstable modes those
will work faster uh than if you start
from this perspective and don't know the
numbers
that if you use this algorithm and then
put a put a different regret I'll get
them on top can you have improving that
so so so that so you would need a you so
the parallel to this which somebody
should prove maybe uh us maybe somebody
else uh is that uh if you know there's a
small number of unstable modes and you
know a stabilizing controller you can
have uh regret this independent event
that would be a very nice result uh and
so empirically it works I'll say that
um but yeah but that's an open question
to sort of do that sort of to take a
result like this and do it for regret
I think your algorithm they do you think
I know if they are smoothness or do you
think you need another algorithm to
achieve some goodness for the MTS
problem yeah
submitted it yesterday uh I don't know
I don't know enough to uh say concretely
I would expect that it would get
smoothly so if I if I if you asked me to
that right now that would I don't know
what the odds I would give are but it
would be on that side
foreign
yeah so so imagine you know if you're
gonna do uh if you're gonna answer
this question
where the model stream online you're
going to need some stochastic assumption
on the instance that it's arriving to be
able to start learning and so then you
have the opportunity to say
is there an average case version of
consistency for example that you can
prove learning rates for consistency and
that would depend both on the meta
algorithm and the learning you're doing
here and I think those are very
interesting because really I mean
consistency is a very beautiful way of
defining but in some sense
you know the consistency a learning
person might want is one based on
average case results because you're
designing the learning algorithm under
some assumptions on the instances and so
under those assumptions is the space
where you really might want consistency
and that's a different constraint than
the adversarial notion of consistency
that most of them
okay thank you thanks for staying to the
end
I uh I'm the last one up here I guess
that's my job I thank the organizers as
well so thank you
[Applause]